that venue is now a scene of crime and
it will be it will be the forensic
analysis of that particular venue the
arena which will reveal I suspect
several key important issues which will
aid the investigation that will be that
will be about to be launched and be out
and be you know on on going for so for
some considerable time but there's also
another key element to this and that is
the role of intelligence what we will
the agencies would have known or maybe
not know at all about this individual
will be key to the context of why this
offense what why this tragic event was
perpetrated and also the context to it
for me personally I feel it's symbolic
the fact that we're in the middle of a
general election campaign Greater
Manchester has been very much
in the end of the forefront of people's
minds in relation to elections with the
election of amerli recently and I feel
that as a contributing factor as to why
this venue has been as being singled out
for this attack
you
you